so
i'm going to aim this cookie projection
behind his
base of support so don't wait here and
stop it
but aim it behind that
okay all right so just like any cookie
projection
the you have to have the the ground path
so your technique must have an element
of stillness in it
you can it's not a matter like people
think or you're using your body momentum
that's not aikido's uh projecting
energy okay so i have to have a ground
pass his energy hits that
and that's what moves him so when i'm
coming in like this
i have to think about where that this
back foot needs to be
in order to do the projection
so if the backwood is moving he's bigger
than me
i'll bounce off of him or will clash
because i'm not internalizing his energy
or
if i put it in a place where he can't do
it
this is all wrong so
if you look at the technique as as i've
closed in
it's always easier to go forward into
the eye of the storm once you've
committed the forward
than it is to go back okay so that's
what's happening here
so i came in and i'm gonna keep going in
i'm gonna keep going and usually what
happens
is you're training you don't you don't
want to go in because that sword is
coming here
but you have to have a spirit that uh
you
are going in you're going in
and then that will stop your back foot
from being uh
placed in a in a zone where it doesn't
actually function as a projection okay
so you're going to move it
then also don't look up at the store
because as you start out it's harder to
do projections when you don't have an
organized body
and the top of your spine should be the
top of your head
you look up like this you it's going to
be harder for a beginner to use a
projection
so don't look in move forward
okay